well the Conor McGregor Floyd Mayweather
fight is so big that it lands on the
weekend I was supposed to do DC now
granted a lot of my fans are fight fans
but but even the improve defense arts
lights lights they were like hey listen
do you want to cancel this and I told
you that I was in the room with you our
agent right we're going on my schedule
he goes up right as I went whoa
cancel everything anyone you have that
love came to me came to us first
I can't believe we're going to do it I
was like I don't know and they're like
listen you know I don't know and the
truth is Saturday might be a ghost town
because of this fight everybody's gonna
be watching it yeah they all new ones
but you never have I ever have a club
come to a headliner girl yeah they just
played in that's how you loops so I'm
gonna tell you know that Conor McGregor
has is a bigger draw than I am this why
this wound fascinating is what Comics
egos oh you might now still do it good
lot to people show up yeah good luck one
day when they told me I went no you
can't do that too bad no one will show
up there will be no one yeah you did to
me completely come on down see Bryan
Callen and his comedy stylings except I
didn't record the Phi the Mayweather
verify cuz this guy is hilarious it's
crazy and like phlegm fistfight with
tables flying and they wouldn't I was
like should we stop the show and the
owner got on the back Mike nope nope
we're going to take care of it well away
and they just let the fight happened a
hockey brawl yeah
and then eventually cleared out and I
continued on with my set as if it's a
good thing I grew up in an Irish boozy
family where you're used to like nothing
to see here folks
yeah yeah just drunk guys is burning out
their angry spirit yeah it's all over I
was in Kansas City and I was doing
Stamford and sons or Sanford and Son
skimmer and the welcome of the club yeah
it's called Sanford and Son and that's
right and it by the way it's in a mall
and then in the middle of nowhere and
I'm all but a mall in the middle of
nowhere where they have those stores
that like the jockey outlet you know
those kinds of stores if you don't I
mean and then other stores like you know
socks race different socks and like
there's nothing
there's a Starbucks of course so and
there's a Dave & Buster's into all the
food where you end up eating every every
meal because that's all the worst food
in the world but yep that's right and
yeah and it gave us a blizzard
yeah Blizzard happened and they had to
well nobody was going to show up to my
show and they didn't and I I was I was
stuck I was stuck in my hotel room and I
never forgot I think was Will Arnett one
of my buddies was doing some big movie
and he had his own TV show and then
Bradley Cooper was starting to get
famous these were all my kind of friend
contemporaries hi miss and yeah Brett
all right yeah and then a couple other
guys were just killing it and I was I
remember sitting in the Best Western I
think it was the Best Western doesn't
matter it was like that or the best
Webster is probably like better than it
was okay of stuff it was new it was very
new clean and I was sitting in my in my
hotel room alone while it was
blizzarding out and there's nowhere to
go and there was a Bible I remember I
opened during there was a Bible and
there's a Bible and there was a and then
I was and there was porn I could have
watched on TV there was a like literally
porn and I was like I could watch porn
or read the but that's where I'm at
right now your choices as it yeah and
then I this is so weird that it was
nighttime and I got hungry and I walked
I had rented a car and I was walking
down this business bang bang and I swear
to god this this beat-up Toyota let's
just call it a Corolla wanna why don't
we bring it back and these dudes these
are what looked like migrant workers I
mean long hair but but like they look
mean and I swear to God the guy goes
I've never I've never felt threatened
where I was worried and I'm in Kansas in
a blizzard and the guy goes hey man want
to play with us you want to come play
with us and I was like I'm about to get
[ __ ] robbed or killed or rain I said
I never forgot I think it was a sexual
kind of weird predatory thing and I went
I went police as police I just pointed
over there I got her police over there I
just kind of randomly pointed and said
police and then kind of uh and I'll
it was [ __ ] terrifying I would have
just disappeared in a puff of of snow
yeah no trace of Brian as he's dragged
into a car anyway I did [ __ ] the guys
but the point is right I'm sure at least
there's a part of you that had to say
like it it's always a little bit of a
compliment to be threatened with with
with retina gang-raped by migrant
workers least you know you still got I
still got it I'm grabbing some food last
night at a barn bar like dinner area in
Brooklyn and this town there's a guy
comes up to me
I go you ever try give me a shitty
accent here and he goes shop [ __ ] a
man eyes what the [ __ ] yours aren't you
a little embarrassed that just how I was
his name are Tommy friend his aren't you
embarrassed
you leave Brian has his friend there
from some old TV and he goes some old TV
show because and I'm listening to I go
yeah I heard I heard it's pretty good
now who's they get emotional yes this
[ __ ] guy because I'm Lister with my
girl and she goes oh baby I feel bad for
Gus and I hearing his friend [ __ ]
died two years ago
this guy's in here in studio crying
because he gets back two years gonna go
bro and he's like shouting at me I go
bro and there's I'm taking pictures of
things but your pride and seen this I
have no argument here I haven't seen the
show I don't know what's going on and he
goes this [ __ ] grown man man this
[ __ ] grown man bro
he's crying friend died two years ago
two [ __ ] years ago might I do I'm
just laughing squeegees going to [ __ ]
years ago [ __ ] this grown man crying
crying in your studio did you leave you
got another man crying I go yeah I've
cried in there before you not not after
a [ __ ] friend dies two years ago yo
yeah it sounds like it's really painful
though man I don't know when he goes you
got a [ __ ] listen man I'm like I will
have a good day you're so funny good oh
then he often codes yours and you leave
and I start dropping [ __ ] hand bombs
when was it okay to drop in bombs on
your show I'm like hold up Brian drop
down my goes yeah yeah I did and the
[ __ ] cried
baby join in on it I'm like I don't know
and so I'm like what the [ __ ] happened
brothers god this grow hate crying
disguise of a above heels you leave for
one [ __ ] day he's dropping and bombs
on it oh man I don't know bro I hate I
don't know what to tell you is anyway
man
have a nice [ __ ] night what salts
thank you
picture nah [ __ ] you he didn't say that
when she did though
I thought those hilarious dumb history
flight I'm sure next week when getting
to fighting the kid Brian Brian a
breakdown yeah I started finding a hey
man you dropped in bombs I'm fighting me
kid
that's a no-no and he goes we'll talk
next week oh if you drop their bombs
we're talking now definitely can have
that but I think it's out of touch yeah
he obvious looking at O'Brien did it in
context though the guy's like much to
end bombs lovely guy did droppin bombs
no not saying the other guy I was talkin
eeeh he's precious he just heard the end
bomb I'll get just he didn't talk about
it in context all right so it was it was
decent it was there's a reason for it so
yeah all right well we shall see